mesdames messieurs bienvenue à à vous
tous dans ce nouvel établissement de
korian guyancourt une soixantaine de
personnes était réunie ce mardi 4
juillet pour l'inauguration officielle
de la nouvelle clinique privée korian le
grand parc
cet établissement de 6000 mètres carrés
situé dans le quartier du pont du
routard pour accueillir une centaine de
patients pour une durée moyenne d'une
trentaine de jours ici on dont traite
des patients qui ont subi une
intervention chirurgicale et on les
réhabilite pour qu'ils puissent
reprendre leur vie normale
donc nous sommes la suite logique de la
médecine interventionnelle donc vous
avez dans le secteur international une
opération et les gens derrière ont
besoin d'un certain nombre de pratiques
de rééducation qui sont donnés ici et
qui leur permettent de retrouver une vie
tout à fait normale dans cette troisième
cliniques du groupe implantée dans les
yvelines les patients sont pris en main
par plus de 124 salariés dont 80 sont
spécialisées dans les soins les méthodes
qui a séduit la mairie il ya quatre ans
avec 10% de sa population âgée de plus
de 60 ans la ville espère avec cet
établissement répondre au mieux aux
attentes des seniors de la commune à
guyancourt on essaye d'avoir une offre
de soins là la plus importante pour les
uhlans pour toi on à la maison de cure
et disciplinaire de santé qui va ouvrir
ses portes au mois de septembre un
projet effectivement partenariat avec
les médecins du secteur
et puis cette clinique de soins qui va
compléter sa sera très intéressant pour
l'ensemble du lion courtois qui ont déjà
commencé à investir cette fille nique
dans le cadre de sud de soins coût total
des travaux 16 millions d'euros
entièrement prise en charge par des
financements privés